David.
What do you believe the consequences will
be to the Trump coup, insurrectionist riot?
So it's still too early to know.
But for me, the questions are what will be
the consequences for Trump in the Republican
Party?
I'm going to deal with that in a second segment
because that requires much more time on its
own.
What will be the consequences for the rioters?
What will be the consequences for the country?
And what will be the consequences for Joe
Biden, who's about to be sworn in in the midst
of absolute insanity?
So for the rioters, it's quite simple.
This now becomes a law enforcement operation.
The rioters need to be identified and they
need to be arrested, processed, charged, and
get them into the justice system and start
working through what what is going on.
Many of them already have.
We've started to see collections of Trump's
mug shots be put together.
And these are folks who should be dealt with
seriously.
We already talked about how how would this
have gone differently were this a group of
black protesters, antifa, black lives matter?
It would have been dramatically different
from the start.
Well, we're beyond that now.
The question is, how is the justice system
going to deal with these folks?
And we need to see that process through.
And for the rioters, listen, many of them
are many of them have lost jobs.
Lawmakers have resigned.
We have seen people ostracized by communities.
We've seen all sorts of different things.
You know, a lot of people get their lives
ruined via interactions with police that never
even should be police interactions here.
Some people are going to get their lives ruined
or at least temporarily ruined because they
made really bad decisions and did did horrible
things.
And so that's that's the path forward for
the rioters, for the country.
I had a segment on Monday about this, and
we're really at a precipice.
We shouldn't understate.
You know, I said this when we were voting
Hillary versus Trump in 2016.
Anybody saying Trump, Hillary, it's the same
anybody saying, I don't really know that in
practical terms, it's much of a difference.
They were wrong and we were talking about
the importance of that decision four years
ago.
And likewise, we are either going to see the
country recognize that even though we're not
all on the same page politically, that what
happened over the last 10 days goes beyond
politics and that it cannot be allowed in
any way.
It can't be allowed in our communities at
a microcosm level.
It can't be allowed at the federal level,
at the state level, that this this is not
valid politics.
And that would be the ideal thing.
And as I said, it's going to require some
Republicans to say, I don't like what Trump
how Trump did his presidency.
I am for things like low taxes, low regulation,
et cetera, that are typically more Republican
things.
I don't see them in Joe Biden, but Joe Biden
is the president.
And we have to come together and simply respect
that.
It doesn't mean we don't disagree when Joe
Biden does something we don't like.
And that applies to us on the left as well.
That's one path forward.
The other path forward is that this type of
riotous insurrection becomes, unfortunately,
more common and considered valid politics
by too many people.
And it's a very dangerous precipice.
So what what it means for the country, we
will soon see for Joe Biden, I actually think
that to some degree this has been good for
Joe Biden.
And I want to be really careful.
There's never anything good in in in practice
from these riotous coup attempts or what we
saw.
But there is some degree to which I believe
and hope more people than otherwise would
be are better predisposed to the Biden presidency
because it means Trump goes and that that
has to happen.
And so I think that Democrats could not possibly
if you had said to Democrats, what can you
come up with that would happen within two
weeks of Biden's swearing in.
That would best position Biden to get started.
I don't think they could have come up with
anything more beneficial than the Trump is.
Right.
Completely humiliating itself.
Now, I know lots of people liked what the
Trump right did.
There are millions of people who support what
the Trump is right.
Did, but there are many, many Republicans
who don't.
And when it comes to the officials who said,
oh, you know, I'm quitting now, it's too little,
too late.
Chris Christie, Lisa Murkowski, etc..
It's too little, too late, guys.
You don't get to have your reputations rehabilitated.
But for the presumably millions of Trump voters
that are disgusted with what's going on, I
believe their disgust will better position
Joe Biden for his entry into office.
And that's my hope.
Whether it will work out that way or not remains
to be seen.
Now, let's talk about what this does to Trump
and the Republican Party.